hallo und herzlich willkommen zum
Treffen der Anonymen Adventskalender
Süchtigen heute geht es um den Kalender
von Paul Valentina ein Schmuck
Adventskalender der toll sein soll wurde
mir gesagt und deswegen testen wir den
heute nach dem ersten Adventskalender
Video wo ich den Schmuck von Six
getestet habe ist mir aufgefallen ich
vertrage Schmuck das hat sich irgendwie
ein bisschen geändert oder der SIX
Schmuck ist besonders gut was ich jetzt
eigentlich nicht glaube aber ja was kann
ich euch zu Paul Valentina erzählen nee
ehrlich gesagt nicht fehlt das muss ich
jetzt erstmal googeln dieser Kalender
wurde von euch sehr oft vorgeschlagen
bin ich ehrlich 59 € kostet z.B jetzt
eine Halskette das heißt wir befinden
uns noch nicht bei Thomas Sabo aber auch
noch ganz weit weg von sixx höherer
Mittelstand alles klar also hier steht
schon mal 14 Karat Gold Planet es ist
quasi Modeschmuck aus Edelstahl mit 14
Karat Gold überzogen erst gar nicht
schlecht ich muss ja sagen ich kenne
mich ja gut aus mit Adventskalendern
aber wenn es jetzt um sowas geht um
wirklich zu bewerten ob der Schmuck
seinen preiswert ist wie die
Verarbeitung ist da müsst ihr euch
professionellere Meinungen zu anhören
ich gebe euch einfach ein Bauchgefühl
ein gutes Bauchgefühl der Kalender
kostet
159,90 € und soll einen wahren Wert
haltet euch fest von
572 Euro haben du sparst
412 Euro also wenn das nicht mal ein
Top-Angebot ist man kann den Kalender je
nach Geschmack in Gold Silber oder
Roségold bestellen und ich bin der
Meinung ich habe Gold ausgesucht was
soll ich optisch sagen wir haben 160 €
für das Ding bezahlt natürlich sollte
das was her machen der macht mich
irgendwie aggressiv dass da fällt alles
wir haben hier eine wunderschöne
Schleife die wir jetzt gemeinsam öffnen
Dieter
hier wir haben hier an der Seite eine
Büchlein was verrät dieses Büchlein
nichts da ist jetzt sich um einen
Schmuck Adventskalender handelt habe ich
natürlich noch keinen an damit ich ganz
viel mehr dran quatschen kann ich weiß
nicht wie das andere hinkriegen und
warum das hier nicht so ist aber das
fällt ziemlich leicht raus also man muss
echt aufpassen dass einem die Kartons
nicht flöten gehen falls die Erfahrung
mit Paul Valentina habt könnt ihr es ja
gerne mal in die Kommentare schreiben es
würde mich mal interessieren ob das ein
sehr bekanntes Ding ist und warum ich
das eigentlich noch nicht kannte Nummer
eins ist so schön Gold wow ich bin jetzt
echt gespannt ne also der Schmuck von 6
war ja teilweise echt nicht so bombe
toll eingepackt super sicher secure
that's what we love oh mein Gott den
Look Diamond
oh ich fühle mich wie die Frauen wie bei
QVC die Artikelnummer ist
2589 hier einmal unser Diamant toll
tolles Geschenk für die Frau oder für
Ihr Enkelkind oh oh oh
wie das glitzert wie ist sie verarbeitet
er tip top toll das ist natürlich nicht
sixniveau aber das zu macht Ding als
ganz stabil das erste Türchen ist
eigentlich das wichtigste weil das setzt
die ganze Stimmung für den Kalender
okay mama mama beide hallo Mama 2 ja
also es fällt schon sehr leicht raus
hier alles ne oh das sieht aus wie eine
Uhr Schachtel
ah ich habe da wohl was nicht ganz
richtig verstanden da haben wir einen
color Collection Shampoo das kann ich
mir jetzt hier so äh ran hängen wow
toller Anhänger jetzt geht's aber schon
los hier ne es ist Zeit für mein kleines
dickes Notizbuch wer nämlich mit 550 €
Warenwert prahlt gucken wir noch mal
ganz genau der liederpreis ist 79 80
wenn ein Liter 71 € kostet
100 ml 7,10 € und dann kostet ein halber
Milliliter 3 € 55 für die Kette marien
50er Leute
gespannt auf die Türchen Nummer drei
Kabuki Make-up brush
[Musik]
oh perfekt für meine asmr Videos falls
ihr nicht mein asmr Kanal kennt schaut
doch mal gerne vorbei der Loni Bauer
kamuki-pinsel ist für ein makelloses
verblenden von Puder auf der Haut
prädestiniert durch das sehr dicht und
festgebundene Haar lässt sich auch
Bronzer und Rouge besonders gut auf dem
Gesicht verteilen 18 Euro 18 Euro
Türchen Nummer vier da kommt wieder
Schmuck auf uns zu
jawollo das ist wieder was zu lange den
Armband meine Damen und Herren die
Produktnummer
552 heute ein Armband im aktuellen
Tagesangebot also wirklich auch wieder
ein fantastisches Geschenk für die
Enkelkinder also Armbänder müssen auch
in einer Zeit erfunden worden sein wo
die Adligen noch so von Leuten angezogen
wurden weil ich das nicht verstehe wie
man das sich selbst machen kann
okay vergessen
wow tolles zartes Armband was wir uns
jetzt nicht dran machen
ich würde 35 Euro sagen aber auch
wirklich nur aus gutem Willen weil das
ist wirklich ein Hauch dünnes Armband
der macht mich irgendwie aggressiv dass
da fällt alles ich weiß also ja klar der
muss halt so stehen damit er stabil
stehen kann verstehe ich schon alles gut
aber der ist so
Nummer 5 und das ist so schwer da sind
wahrscheinlich 30.000 Ringe drin
nein Nagellack Opi ein Nagellack sieht
einfach toll aus ich weiß nicht warum
das hat sowas hochwertiges das sieht
richtig aus der ist auch teuer oder Opi
14 €, ne ist das teuer ich denke mal mit
so einem Nagellack kann man nicht viel
falsch machen ich finde auch die Farbe
ist total passend es ist genau die Farbe
die man zur Weihnachtszeit haben möchte
deswegen
tipptopp ihr wisst der Kalender steht
und fällt mit der Nummer 6 ach Nikolaus
gibt es schwul manchen irgendwelchen
Adventskalender Sitzungen sagen sich so
die Leute das an der sechsten Türchen
was wichtiges drin sein muss weil sonst
zerreißt Vanessa den Kalender oh oh ja
Mensch ja finde ich generell schön
schlichte Ringe oh
toll verarbeitet lassen sich ganz easy
auf und zu machen ja fühlen sich gut an
sehen gut aus ja sind ganz ganz
schlichte Ringe so wie beim anderen
Schmuck ist halt sehr sehr schlicht wir
haben sie gar nicht die Produkte
oval Hoops das sind sie 35 €. wir machen
40 €. ich weiß ja nicht ob ihr es
wusstet ne aber dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsert und jetzt alle die dieses
Videos nicht geschossen und ich habe
auch keine Ahnung von Schmuck das sind
alles hier nur Schätzungen ne wenn ich
Preise sage wie viele Schmuck wert ist
oder kostet ist das alles nur meine
Meinung dafür kann ich mich besser mit
Limonade aus und die bionale Litschi ist
die leckerste Limonade die es auf der
Welt gibt Türchen Nummer 7
das sieht cool das ist so cool aus oh
mein Gott was ist das Reset Louis Öl in
serum im Hotel Reset ich glaube das ist
ein Nacht sehr rum okay also 10 ml
kosten
19,67 € heißt für diese 5 berechnen wir
10 €. und was ist das Anti-Aging Pflege
also Öl was man über die Nacht ins
Gesicht schmieren soll dazu kann ich
euch jetzt auch nicht sagen da müsst ihr
bei X skincare vorbeischauen wenn ihr
euch für
weiter geht's mit Türchen Nummer ach ne
das ist toll und jetzt haben wir wieder
Schmuck ich bin noch nicht ganz sicher
ob ich es besser oder schlechter finde
dass da nicht immer nur Schmuck drinne
muss ich am Ende urteilen oh
mein Gott die Produktnummer 542 ich
würde jetzt als Nasenring benutzen wird
mir stehen hier noch mal meine jüngeren
Zuschauer steckt euch niemals was in die
Nase nicht wie Tante Vanessa das ist sie
macht das jetzt hier nur aus weil sie
erwachsen ist und Sachen einschätzen
kann
ja ist
vergiss es hier sieht es toller aus
steckt euch nicht in die Nase 15 €. es
ist winzig klein es ist nur ein Teil 15
Euro und das ist ja schon viele Nummer 9
ist wieder
super oh mein Gott bald da das beste nee
die großen und schweren Sachen sind ja
nicht die besten okay bevor ich sehe was
es ist es riecht wie das
läusenentfernungswasser Goldgeist 1:1
als ich mal Läuse als Kind hatte hat das
entfernungs Zeug genau so gerochen
was Parfum ist richtig Goldgeist also
hier drin riecht mal
das ist Goldgeist wie kann das sein und
es ist mein oh mein Gott
Rituals hat ja verschiedene Linien die
bekannteste ist glaube ich cherry
blossom dann gibt es noch rote grüne und
die haben alle ganz tolle Namen und
meine lieblingslinie ist die goldgelbe
Ritual of mehr und das ist jetzt das
Parfum dazu homeparfum Stimmrecht das
ganz toll wenn man das mal raussprüht
oh das riecht toll das riecht toll ich
nehme alle meine Aussagen zurück es
riecht nicht nach Läusen entfernungszeug
es riecht fantastisch es ist meine
Lieblingssorte von Rituals und ich liebe
es weil timo hat ein grünes homeparfum
und ich kann jetzt mein Zimmer auch noch
voll stinken und dann riecht unsere
ganze Wohnung wie ein Rituals Laden
perfekt mit guter Laune geht es weiter
in Tschechen Nummer 10 findet sich
natürlich
super bekommen wir endlich unseren Ring
oh das ist
noch sehr schlau gemacht weil natürlich
jeder eine andere Ringgröße hat und mit
diesem offenen Teil hier unten kann man
sich das ein bisschen anpassen gut
gelöst ich kann aber nicht nur ein Ring
tragen ich muss mehrere Ringe tragen ich
habe das also ich habe keine Ringe aber
immer wenn ich einen Ring trage fühle
ich mich als ob ich so ein bisschen so
tue als ob ich verlobt wäre also was ich
meine so ja er hat mich gefragt nach 5
Jahren endlich Nummer 11 Mama will
Schmuck ja
nicht noch ein Armband nicht noch ein
Armband nicht noch ein Armband nein es
wird Zeit für eine Kette gewesen das
gefällt mir mehr das ist so da ist ein
bisschen mehr dran die 0254 ne jetzt
noch schnell bestellen wir haben noch 27
im Vorrat und danach ist das
Tagesangebot auch erstmal weg
komm Vanessa du hast nicht umsonst nicht
studiert ich habe es nicht ich weiß
nicht wie das andere Leute machen
haha toll wenn man 90 viel im Leben
erreicht ist das auch ein schönes Ding
machen wir 40 dafür lass mich mal kurz
überlegen was für ein Preis ich mir
dafür ausdenke 40 €. Nummer 12 ist groß
Wiedersehen macht Freude der ist nicht
so gut bei Daniela Katzenberger war ein
einer drin der hat sich besser angefühlt
und jetzt ist der wieder von Loni und
Bauer ein eileash Curler ja
Wimpernzange auch 18 so die Hälfte ist
jetzt schon um Nummer 13
remeda ist ein Produkt aus dem Hause
Luki kannte ach kommt als ob ihr wisst
wie das ausgesprochen wird lokitane der
kleine wunderbalsam reichhaltige
universal Pflege lindet das Gefühl
kleiner durch Trockenheit verursachte
Hautirritation fliegt intensiv besonders
sanfte Pflege für die Körperstellen die
sie am meisten brauchen Lippen Ellbogen
Fersen Nagelhaut oh riecht sehr nett
also
noch riecht hochwertig und natürlich
wollen wir eine doppelte Schicht wow
habt ihr schon mal so strahlende
Ellbogen gesehen die werde ich den
Winter überleben 12 Euro ist schon sehr
sehr viel ne
meine Speicher gerade war gerade voll
und deswegen wollte ich halt eine andere
rein machen dann bin ich aufgestanden
und habe aus Versehen den
Adventskalender mit mir mitgerissen und
jetzt ist da nichts mehr drin ja die
sind aber es ist so an es ist so fragil
das ist so guck mal das
gehört es so dass es nee das ist geklebt
und es geht immer also auf und es ist so
man könnte doch erwarten dass der
einfach stehen kann ich will jetzt hier
nichts falsches sagen aber er
wahnsinnig beruhigt habe ich mich jetzt
noch nicht
jetzt können wir weiter reden
jetzt hat man hier endlich mal Platz da
muss ich mich nicht so neben den
Kalender quetschen ich habe heute nicht
Sonnenuntergang ich weiß nicht was
manchmal hat man solche Tage und jetzt
gucken wir was in der 14 drin ist
Schmuck wir lieben Schmuck oh oh hier
ist wow also so klein und fein Schmuck
weil ich lange nicht mehr wirklich der
kleinste Ohrring der Welt ganz klein
aber auch wieder toll am glitzernde die
verkaufen nicht mal die Produkte die sie
in dem also es gibt keinen so winzig
kleinen Stecker hier ist das 30 €. so
unsere Goldene Zahl 30 wir haben jetzt
nichts in der Kollektion ist auch nur
annähernd so klein und und simpel 15 oh
Nagellack von OPI ja auch schön ist
nicht so Tipp-Ex weiß es ist eher so ein
äh doch ein angenehmes weiß oh das habe
ich hier
16 Schmuck oh
und da haben wir Sie die passende Kette
zum Armband mit der Artikelnummer 364
können Sie diese Kette bestellen die ist
schön oh das könnte meine neue
Lieblingskette sein
oh toll na gut zusammenpassen jetzt
nicht aber was haben wir 50 € Kosten
oh da sieht man dass die in Kooperation
zusammenarbeiten lokithane die habe ich
glaube ich noch vom Amazon beauty
Adventskalender ist eine tolle Creme
also was soll man sagen ist eine schöne
Qualität das fühlt sich hochwertig an
toll toll toll toll Luciano 150 wie viel
ist hier 33 boah 1/5 von 18 ja
Nummer 18 lieber Adventskalender Gott
bitte lass das Schmuck drin sein
ja
endlich
größere toll zum Vergleich die davor
waren so groß und jetzt haben wir so
große schön die Basic [ __ ] hier
raushängen lassen aber das ist nicht
schlimm das ist auch manchmal gut so ich
trag da mal ganz salopp 35 Euro ich
meine mal gucken was wir am Ende für den
Preis raus haben ich mache da auch gerne
und Maus Kulanz und Paul Euro hin oder
her natürlich ist dieses Ding wieder so
groß weil da eine 9 drauf ist und der
Adventskalender gott liebt meinen geil
das möchte ich unbedingt ausprobieren
das ist botanical infused hair Serum und
wisst ihr warum ich ein paar Serum haben
möchte weil die in diesen asmr Videos wo
sie dann immer dieses Bar Behandlung
kriegen und die Kopfhaut gewaschen und
so da kriegen die auch immer so ein
Tonic Wasser auf die Kopfhaut und nicht
mehr so mal ja ich brauche auch einen
Tonic Wasser für meine Kopfhaut oh mein
Gott Leute Schein Labs hat seinen Sitz
am Kurfürstendamm das ist so Buschi der
Liter kostet 1 2 3 Euro dann kostet 100
m Kommentar 1 2,3 Euro und dann kosten
50 ml die Hälfte davon 6,1520
Leute das mögen wir nicht nicht zwei
gleiche Produkte hintereinander wieder
ein Dings von Schein color protect
Conditioner hier hatten wir das Color
protect Shampoo und jetzt gibt es den
passenden sieht schon schön aus machen
wir 4 €, weil das sind ganz schön
twenty one Leute
jetzt kommen sie noch mal ich weiß nicht
ob ich diese Farbe zum Kotzen finde oder
wunderschön was sagt ihr 14 € waren 22
oh die wollte uns austricksen die Box
sie sah so groß aus aber da ist Schmuck
drin ich habe es gemerkt oh oh
[Musik]
kriegt man eigentlich auch mehrere
Armbänder und kriegt doch mir geringe
ich kann das nicht ich kann es nicht
okay schönes Armband
packen wir rein 40 € alles klar haben
uns alle lieb okay 40 €
twentythree 23 ist sehr schwer das
bedeutet ich sag Creme aber luciante
kitane schaue oil oh Duschöl auch was
zum Waschen unter der Dusche ich wenn
ich das Öl habe und dann ist sich so mit
Wasser vermischt und es soll ja
irgendwie so sein und dann ist man ölig
unter der Dusche nee ich muss mich ich
muss mich abschrubben ich muss direkt
wegmachen und dann ist gut dann
vielleicht noch danach eincremen aber
nicht unter der Dusche irgendwie Öl das
kommt auf jeden Fall in die
verlosungsbox da könnt ihr euch aber
sicher sein das Lucky tarne schaueroil
mit Mandeln kostet 6,50 dafür
Weihnachten Weihnachten oh mein Gott an
Weihnachten wird jetzt was so tolles
Treffen sein das 24 Türchen wird hier
grandios da könnt ihr euch aber sicher
sein dass 24 Türchen es ist Weihnachten
ich Glitzer an meinem Körper so doll wie
meine Glitzer Lichterkette denn ich
Funke wie ein kleiner Stern dank Paul
Valentina und dann gehe ich zu meinem
letzten Türchen und finde noch einen
Schmuckkästchen und dann freue ich mich
und mach ihn auf und denk mir wird das
das Schmuckstück sein was ich heute
Abend an Heiligabend tragen werde wer
weiß es sieht schon besonders aus es hat
sogar ein ganz kleines Plättchen dran
und auf diesem Plättchen ja das
es ist ein Plättchen das ist eine Kette
wow wie WoW ja doch das ist
[Musik]
schön oh nein ziehe ich mir jetzt hier
die Kette an und dann freue ich mich
denn ich habe schöne Kette also wir
gucken jetzt erstmal die Kette da sage
ich auch wieder 50 € nehmen ich hätte
mir noch gerne mehr Ringe gefunden weil
dieser Ring ist echt schön und der sitzt
gut bevor wir über den Preis sprechen
finde ich die Auswahl gut ich habe sehr
viel Schmuck an mir dran ich muss aber
ehrlich sein dass der Schmuck ist mir zu
schüchtern also der ist zu basic in
allen also alle Ohrringe sind total die
Basic Ohrringe der Ring ist basic die
Kette und das also das finde ich ich
finde das alles schön finde es aber sehr
basic aber man spart ja extrem das heißt
man kriegt ja schon mehr für sein Geld
die Produkte finde ich alle aus der dass
Duschgel finde ich gut ich meine das ist
Handcreme ellbogencreme
das ist alles was man im Winter schon
braucht Favorit absoluter und das
Shampoo Duschzeug ist ja schon cool
jetzt ist es halt wirklich wichtig
[Musik]
was kostet das alles
okay sechs einhalb Stunden später
okay ich sag nix mehr der Kalender ist
mega cool und wie gesagt ich habe ein
bisschen immer so wahrscheinlich unter
dem Preis gerechnet den sie so berechnen
würden gerade weil es halt eines so
simpler Schmuck ist bin aber bei
511 € rausgekommen
und es ist ja nicht mal so wisst ihr bei
dem Daniela Katzenberger hat mir diese
Augencreme wo man sagt ja
gut 90 Euro für diese Augencreme solche
Produkte hatten wir gar nicht drin wir
haben ja bekannte Marken die ja sogar
sehr beliebt sind scheinbar mir jetzt
unbekannt also die Shampoo Marke habe
ich meinen Rituals kennt man auch und
vor allem den Schmuck hin von was habe
ich dafür
bezahlt 160 €, ne die sagen der Wert
liegt bei 572 €. ich sage der liegt bei
511 € irgendwo dazwischen ist
wahrscheinlich die war aber ich habe
wirklich nur 160 € dafür bezahlt und
habe Produkte im Wert von 511 €. jetzt
ist nur die Frage also ich persönlich
habe für dieses Bändchen jetzt 30 €
berechnet ich würde aber in keiner Welt
im Laden stehen und für 30 Euro mich für
dieses Armbändchen hier entscheiden ne
das ist mir einfach zu wenig zu schlicht
zu da trage ich lieber nichts als dafür
30 € auszugeben bin ich eher aber die
Ketten finde ich toll die Ohrringe davon
wollte ich also ich wollte die ganze
Zeit solche Creolen haben deswegen freue
ich mich darüber wir brauchen nicht
drüber sprechen der Kalender ist super
und alleine nur wenn man jetzt sagen
würde man bezahlt den Schmuck 160 € 11
Schmuckstücke
und dann nehmen wir die 160 Euro die wir
für diesen Kalender bezahlt haben durch
elf Schmuckstücke wir bezahlen für jedes
Schmuckstück 14,50 € und bekommen quasi
das alles
gratis oben drauf
quasi als Geschenk hätte unter dem
letzten Video gelesen nämlich das sogar
Firmen sich Plätze in Adventskalendern
erkaufen können um dort Werbung zu
machen das heißt es kann sein dass Paul
Valentine gar nicht dafür bezahlt hat
oder sogar bezahlt wird dafür dass Sie
Produkte drin haben das heißt also sie
hatten vielleicht gar keine Ausgaben
dafür trotzdem finde ich so als
Endverbraucher als Konsument hat man
schon was davon und es ist irgendwie
eine schöne Mischung ich finde es toll
weil wenn man sich jetzt ein Nagellack
Adventskalender kauft ja gut dann hat
man 24 Nagellacke hier hat man drei und
man hat Shampoo man hat
Duschöl ja das ist toll ich glaube wenn
ein einziges Problem mit diesem Kalender
war dass ich nicht wirklich die
Zielgruppe bin sondern so eher das
klassische Team Girl bisher Haare schön
nach hinten am besten noch in
irgendeinem Studium hängen die Wohnung
sieht aus wie ein
instagram-foto jedes Kissen wird jeden
Tag frisch ausgeschüttelt und auch
einmal am Tag durchgesaugt und Zahnseide
benutzen vergessen Sie auf keinen Fall
die kreischen wahrscheinlich wenn die so
schlichten Schmuck sehen vor Freude das
ist schon schön
mal gucken was ich davon behalte und was
ich in die Verlosung mit rein packe
folgt mir dafür auf jeden Fall auf
Instagram da werdet ihr die Verlosung
mitbekommen und auch teilnehmen können
über youtube funktioniert das leider
nicht weil ich euch darüber nicht
kontaktieren kann das tut mir leid für
alle die keinen Instagram haben und
ansonsten checkt sehr gerne mein
asmr-kanal aus ich habe den hier auch
verlinkt und da könnt ihr ja asmr wie
das Schauen ich bin da wieder sehr aktiv
und sehen uns das nächste mal wieder und
ich werde jetzt erstmal
den Kalender befüllen alles
durcheinander
tschüss